les récits de guerre l'ont fait
connaître mais c'est raboliot pour
lequel il obtient en 1925 le prix
goncourt à 35 ans qui consacre maurice
genevoix comme l'écrivent plus qu'une
célébration des paysages de sologne
ce roman raconte le combat d'un
braconnier pour sa liberté dans un monde
de plus en plus normé et réglementer le
mot n'existait pas à l'époque mais vu le
portrait qu'il dresse des gendarmes
on peut dire aujourd'hui au risque de
l'anachronisme que c'est aussi un livre
anti flics sais pas si vous voulez un
libertaire c'est un non conformiste et
un an conformisme instinct c'est pas du
tout un contestataire il ne démontre
rien il ne s'oppose à rien il est ce
qu'il est et il ya des choses qui ne
comprend pas certaines contraintes
sociales d'ailleurs moi non plus j'aime
autant vous le dis il ya des papiers
contre toi risée vue à la gendarmerie
c'est pas avec leurs papiers qui peuvent
mettre la main dessus et dangereuses à
respirer
il ya ce qu'a dit et peut-être qu'à
autre chose encore c'est pas moi c'est à
croire que les arbres ont des yeux elle
va t'en va t'en raboliot battant vite
il a écrit le roman emblématique de la
sologne
mais maurice genevoix l'observent en
voisin car son territoire son port
d'attache c'est la loire je suis né sur
les bords de la loire nombre à
châteauneuf mais à 2,6 et même dans une
île de la loire dans la nièvre dans la
nième et c'est dans une île de la loire
alors j'étais dans le haut d'une rue en
pente qui dégringolait presque
automatiquement vers la loi je suis
devenu pêcheur je suis devenu un
fanatique de la loire gelé connu je
vivais dessus au bord de dents si bien
que l s'est incorporé en quelque sorte à
la substance et à ma sensibilité
profonde c'est tout à fait naturel et
normal en 1927 maurice genevoix trouve à
saint denis de l'hôtel
la maison de ses rêves c'est la pause et
au bord du fleuve qu'il écrit ses livres
dont beaucoup sont inspirées par la
nature on le définit alors comme un
écrivain régionaliste et même
écologistes en sologne comme en
allemagne
vous chantez la nature depuis depuis
longtemps cela on dit que vous êtes un
écrivain écologique
le premier est pourtant vous n'êtes pas
un militant écologique pourquoi parce
que c'est pas encore au point si vous
voulez moi je me contente de de dire ce
que je vois ce que je sens d'essayer de
transmettre les tranches d émotion les
jouissances même que j'éprouve au
contact même de la création pour
généraliser au maximum je trouve que la
vie est belle que le monde est beau et
c'est pas une raison aviez courteau si
c'est pas la peine de s'appesantir sur
ce miroir d'eau ou non chalon cette
coulis de lumières changeantes inspire
sa plume et quand il tourne la tête de
l'autre côté vers la forêt genevois ne
se contente pas de parler des animaux
qu'ils rencontrent comme l'écureuil avec
qu'il sympathise il écrit parfois du
point de vue de l'animal si je suis
chasseur bien sûr profondément mais ça
ne veut pas dire que je sois tueur c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose
je suis passionné par la quête par la
recherche par la surprise et j'ai eu au
cours de ma vie en effet des rencontres
absolument passionnante
je serais trop lent de vous raconter
mais je suis chasseur dans l'âme je suis
chasseur d'instinct parce que je suis un
homme complet mais je ne suis pas un
tueur et j'ai séché de l'être pour une
raison bien simple j'ai vu mourir trop
d'être jeunes entre 14 et 18 pour me
plaire à voir couler le sang ça n'est
absolument pas dans les tranchées de 14
genevois n'a pas seulement vu de jeunes
soldats tombés à 20 ans sous les balles
il a aussi vu comment les dombes l'acide
et et le gaz moutarde détruisent
durablement les paysages son amour pour
la nature et son envie de la protéger
viennent également de l'expérience de la
guerre